人に投資してきました。だからうちは
トレーニングカンパニー、つまりノウハウ
を売る会社じゃないんですよ。できるよう
になるまで身につけていたら見込み形態と
受中形態を組み合わせるって発想なんです
。だの尊徳で経用し[音楽]てないという
のが結論なんだよ。青木サの人生額100
回聞いたら豊かになる話。
今回はですね、経営者が学ぶべき持続的利益の思考法というテーマで短期利益と長期利益のバランスの取り方ですね、どのように取ればいいのかというところについて教えていただけますでしょうか?
計学的なアプローチで説明をすることってなかなか長い時間かかっちゃうと思うので、自分はどういう考え方で敬してるかまず
人に投資をしてきました。シンプルにお金
の使い方って消費か老費か投資しかないと
思うんですよ。その中でやっぱり長期的
視点に立った投資ができるかどうかって
いうことがまず長期的視点に立った投資な
んだから、ま、長期的利益はまず確保
できるよね。じゃあ短期的利益って言っ
たら入りのバランスをどう取るかでしょう
。1番何が大事かって経営においては価値
ある商品を[音楽]作るってことなんだよ
。仕入れるとなった時作ったところは価値
ある商品だから別に人に売ってもらわなく
たって売れるわけだよね。それでも仕入れ
させていただくとなったら当然減価は高く
なっちゃうわけよ。だから基本的には
メーカー思考というか自社でコンテンツ
しっかりとしたエビデンスというかな実証
済みの成功理論を私は自分の会社の土台に
置きました。選択さらにはま&
グローリッジ成功哲学でもこれをいくら
知ってても実生活に適用するには
トレーニングしなきゃいけないじゃん。だ
からうちはトレーニングカンパニーなん
です。ここが他の会社と違う、つまり
ノウハウを売る会社じゃないんですよ。
できるようになるまで身につけていただく
。だからある意味であのライズアップに
行くと減量できるじゃん。それ1人では
弱いけどね。ちゃんとアドバイザーがつい
てカロリー管理されて全部報告してそう
すると目標設定して逆算して何減料とか
できるじゃん。つまり1人では弱いけど
パートナーがいるからできることってある
よね。ま、選手だったらコーチがいるとか
アチュメントもそういう存在パワー
パートナーとしてお客様の絆創者として
アチューメントは個人と組織の目標達成の
パートナーでしょ。そういう立ち位置で
ずっと経営してきたよね。ま、僕自身が
若い時からトップセル、トップ
マネージャー、トップコンサルタントとし
て、ま、ピークパフォーマーとして達成型
の人間なので、でも何千冊も本を読み本当
に真剣に農量開発をしてきたベースがある
から、そういう中からかこたるメソロジー
を土台に研修プログラムを設計して、そう
するとある意味ではテキストとかも
ノーハウだから原価はある程度低く抑え
られる。そうすると荒利益は大きいよね。
政策コストを短期間に回収したら、ま、本
もそうですよ。出版のね、因税はずっと
払う。でも、ま、これは8%とか因税は
払い続けるけれど、ま、実際その本って
いうのはインク、紙にインクがで減価は
低くなるわけで、ただ売れるか売れないか
わかんないけど、見込み形態でしょ。て
ことは見込み形態と受中形態を組み合わせ
だ。僕は出版も書店だけに依存するんでは
なく、例えばブランディングのための慈悲
出版で力になってあげるとか。そうすると
これ見込み形態と受中形態を組み合わせ
るって発想になるんですよ。そこで安定的
収益が生まれるとか。だ全部そうなってん
だ。僕は全て僕の発想はつまり見込み形態
はあらりは大きいけど安定が低い。受中
形態は安定性はあるけど利益は低い。それ
を組み合わせればいいじゃないかと。だ、
そういう意味では独的想像力と合成的想像
力、想像力を使いながら仕組みを全部整え
てってるわけ。それで、ま、研修っていう
商品は広告しても広告で来る人よりも立証
済みの成功法に対して受けた人の証が大事
だと僕は思ったわけ。だから自己性
フォローに徹底的にお金を投資をするわけ
だよね。そうするとお客様が味方なって
くれて紹介をくれて87%
とか紹介だもん。だから、ま、もちろん
アチューメント本体があり、HR
ソリューション、これは大企業対象にした
法人研修組織変化コンサルティングをして
いるで出版があると。で、アチューメント
100%子会社ですね。2社でもこれも
うまく空軍、海軍、陸軍とか言って僕は
全部考えてるのよ。で、あとはJPSAと
いう組織があり、それはもう[音楽]うち
のお客様のファンになった人たちの集まり
なんで。で、満足したお客様は協力して
くださるので、ま、大義社会をより良い
社会にしようという目的に対してみんなが
心にして目先の利益を追わずに徹底した
フォローをしていった。目先の尊徳で経営
してないというのが結論なんだよ。長期的
にも短期的にもバランスを持たせながらお
客様満足を追求し、社員満足を追求し、だ
からうちは部合とかも一切ないじゃん。
社会満足イコール納税ですから。ってこと
は利益がないと社会満足を作れないので。
だから適正利潤だけど決して高くはないと
思うんですよ。14万とかね。
テクノロジーコース3日間で。で、私の
構図は、ま、20万しますけ、20数万し
ますけれど、それでも僕が今まで投資して
きた何億という自己投資の金額を3日間で
全部エッセンス話すとなったら高くないと
僕は思ってんですよ。だ、事実うちの受行
生みんなそれ以上リターン得てるじゃない
ですか。要は実行管理までフォローするん
でうちは。そういう意味ではなんだろうな
。目先の忖徳追ってないんだよな。面白い
よね。先の尊徳を追わずにこれだけ公衆
収益の組織体が生まれる。だからある意味
では3年うちは新卒を採用して3年経つと
給料の5倍のありを稼げる人間になるよね
。だそれはどういうことかとやっぱり脂質
の高い人間を入れる。そう支質の高い人を
入れるためには魅力がないとだめじゃん。
魅力って何かって言ったら物共に豊かに
なれる仕組みがあるってことじゃん。そこ
があるから良い循環になってるんじゃない
かと。ま、こっから先はね、3日間僕の
講座に来てもらわないと今の質問はね、
まさに僕の特別講座っていうのは経営者
だけを対象に今のまさに長期と短期の双方
にね、バランスを持たせながら長期的に
おいても短期的においても利益を生み出し
続ける仕組みの想像というそれを目的にし
た講座だからその今本当にエッセンスの
コアになるのマインド面の今話をちょっと
してるだけなんだけどそんな感じかな
ありがとうございます。逆にこう目に見えないが故えにその、過剰に投資しすぎてしまったりですとか、あるいは投資するためのこう、なんていうか踏切りがつかないみたいなことってあると思うんですけど、だからそこのバランスってどんな風に見てる?
あ、これはもう非常にシンプルで、今例えば飛行機ね、操縦してて残りの年どれぐらいあるかとこれで飛ぶ距離を考えなきゃなんだよ。
だからその数字やっぱりそのキャッシュ
フロー財務的に無理しちゃだめです。
やっぱり自分の器ってあるわけよ。だって
うちだって新層作用に踏み切るまでに15
年も買ったんだから。それは僕に責任が
あるね。それはなぜなら、ま、昔横綱千代
の富士の引退記念のプログラム作ってそれ
が一応5000万の在庫になってそれを
売る売り切るのに何年もかかっちゃった。
それが真層作用に踏み切るのを送らせたん
だと思うんだけど、でもストアは言っても
その時にそのプログラムを売り切るために
考えたのがアイデアとして考えたのは研修
ですからね。そのテキストにしてアメリカ
のデイタイマーという手帳をつけて研修を
設計して始まったわけじゃん。だからでも
その本質にあるものは僕は絶対に売り切る
。つまり不誠実に作ってもらったところに
対して迷惑をかけない、ちゃんと売り切る
という責任とか、ま、お客様を味方にする
考え方とか本質的にはやっぱり誠実に僕は
やっぱり対応したと思う。こな間だ
あの柿谷正先生ね、元うちの取締り役の谷
先生があのウィリアムグラスサー博士の
区切りというかいわゆる誕生して何年と
いうねそういう時にメッセージをしてくれ
るっていうことで来てくれて社員相手に
メッセージしてくれたじゃん最後にあそう
だそうそうだ1つ言い忘れたことがある
って覚えてる
はい
で僕をわざわざ読んで青木さん青木さんは
誠実だって言ってくれよね。僕はね、そこ
がポイントじゃないかと思う。やっぱり
信用、信頼
これで最終的にはお客様とも社員とも
お取り先とも協力会社さんとも全部
繋がってるんだと思う。やっぱ相手をね
するような発想勝ち負けじゃないんですよ
、僕は。それは大きいような気がするけど
な。[音楽]
あの、ま、すごく本当に、あの、この根底にあるどんな思想でやっぱりこう、ま、向き合うのかっていうところだったりですとか、そこから出てくるやっぱりそのバランスの取り方っていうのがすごくあるんだなっていうのを感じました。
だから身のたにあった仕事をして短期と長期にまさにバランスを持たせながらつかはこうしてあげたいっていう思いを持ちながら、ま、正直うちの社員にも苦労させた時期があるよ。
社員を見てもみんな誠実な対応してくれる
よねと。だからごまかせないんだよね。
全部実で出てきちゃうから。だ、僕は目先
の尊徳本当に追ってない。バランスだと
思う。ようやく社員にも準利益の3割本当
に還元できる会社になったよね。ま、前期
も3億の感謝放奨金っていう名前で決算書
を出してるわけだけど、僕はすごく嬉しい
です。みんなと信頼関係作ってね、こう
いう企業体に慣れたことだって最初1億の
売上を上げるのも大変だったんだから、
ま、シンプルに目先の利益を追わない、
ふりを追わない。長期的、本質的、客観的
に見て本当にお客様にとって何が良いのか
。そしてあとは自分都合ではなくてお客様
の満足の中に発展反映があるので規模を
追わずに質を確実に着実に1歩ずつ会社を
育てていく。それがま、私が目指してきた
こと。ま、是非ね、あの、コメント欄に、
え、何か感じることあったらコメントお
願いします。そしてチャンネル登録まだで
あれば是非それもお願いします。なんとか
ね、10万人達成目指してますので応援
よろしくお願いします。どうもありがとう
ございました。次回またYouTubeで
お見に帰りましょう。ありがとうござい
ます。
だから、ま、それこそマ金税出身の
コンサルタントがね、僕に青木さん、私は
1時間10万円ですと。青木さんの研修
再行3万円ですよね。て、ま、
スタンダードコースの頃3万円ですと。1
日1万円ですよね。3日間、1日8時間ね
、10時間近くをして3日間最受行量
3万円って1日1万円ですよね。合わない
んじゃないですか。僕やってきますね。て
言ったのよ。僕は彼に言ったのね。その人
に。まるまるさんと。あなたは納品してる
時営業してないでしょ。営業してる時納品
できてないでしょ。分かる?私は再受行し
ていただいて満足してもらうまで徹底的に
サービスフォローするんだよって。で、
技術を習得してもらうことが僕の目的なん
だと。知識をただ売るだけじゃないんだと
。マスターしてもらうことが僕の目的なん
だと。そして物資共もに豊かになって
もらって僕がもらいたい声はありがとうな
んだと。青木さんありがとう。出会えて
よかったと。その時に私は報われるん。
つまり研修の仕事ってそこまでの真心が
ないとやりっぱなしになっちゃったら結果
的にお客さんが集められないって言って
それを広告宣伝とかな広告宣伝してる
コンサルタントろなもんじゃないんだって
俺から言わせるといや本当掘るとか言って
さすごいなんかね資金集めてすっげえ広告
出してるけどま僕から言わせりゃそれは
はっきり言って本物じゃないよね。だって
本当にいい仕事してるならだってお医者
さんにしろ弁護士にしろ会計にしろいい
仕事してたら先生私の友人ちょっと見て
いただけますかとか口込みで広がるだろ
うって。それは技術の証[笑い]でしょっ
ていうのが僕の主張なんですよ。だから
広告宣伝費なんてのは対売上で、ま、本当
23%ぐらいしか使ってなかったんだから
ずっと。ま、最近、ま、アチュメントも
ようやく社会認知されてきたから、
そろそろ広告宣伝してもいいかなと
思い出してますよ。別のあの本田とかはね
、広告宣伝はしますよ、これ。でも研修は
広告する必要ないと。だから
YouTubeは毎回ね、10人ぐらい僕
のこのYouTube見てね、研修にも来
てくださる方も多いので、最近は
ありがたい。感謝してますけど、でもこれ
はね、本当に質のいい人だけが来ますよね
。なぜなら僕のメッセージに共感して来て
くれるからだ。目先の尊徳で経用してな
いっていうのが結論なんだよ。